[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing the
five-time winner of which Weekly's most
charming smile award gilderoy Lockhart
specifically we're going to be taking a
deep dive into this enigmatic Wizard's
life peeling back the layers of his
formative years and figuring out how and
why he turned out the way he did we'll
also be looking at what happened to him
after his last appearance in the books
and films there's a lot of information
on Lockhart so I've tried to narrow it
down to just the most important stuff
let's dive into it Guild warlockant was
a British half-bud wizard born in the
year 1964 to a witch mother and muggle
father he grew up alongside his two
sisters but because they turned out to
be squibs he inevitably became his
mother's favorite being that he was the
only other magical family member
Lockhart was a clever good-looking boy
and when he realized quite early on that
he was magical it went straight to his
head inflating his already massive ego
even further in 1975 at the age of 11
Lockhart first stepped foot through the
doors of Hogwarts School of Witchcraft
and Wizardry to begin his Wizarding
education however Lockhart quickly
realized that Hogwarts was not quite
what he had expected upon stepping foot
in the magical castle he was met with
sheer disappointment suddenly coming to
the crushing realization that at a
school for witches and wizards he was
just another magical young boy in the
Muggle world gilderoy was exceptional
but here he didn't stand out and that's
all he ever longed for during the first
sorting ceremony Lockhart was sorted
into Ravenclaw House narrowly avoiding
being sorted into Slytherin and true to
Ravenclaw Lockhart did do quite well in
his classes but what separated Lockhart
from other ravenclaws was that he didn't
value learning itself he only valued the
attention that good grades brought him
in fact after he began his studies at
the school it became quite evident that
Lockhart was in fact quite clever and
certainly did possess slightly above
average abilities but perhaps the most
crushing blow of all was that none of
what Lockhart achieved was particularly
noteworthy resulting in him more or less
blending in with his peers however it
was this mundane normalcy that lit a
fire inside of young Lockhart and from
very early on he decided that he wanted
to be more to do more he wanted to be
great most of his teachers believed in
him expressing that with enough hard
work he could achieve success even if he
didn't quite reach his Grand Ambitions
but a life of normalcy wasn't what he
wanted and he was quite vocal about his
aspirations sharing with his classmates
his plans to create a philosopher's
stone before leaving school becoming
captain of England's Quidditch team and
eventually going on to become Britain's
youngest ever Minister for magic but
Lockhart didn't stop there in his
Pursuit for attention and validation
during his studies he carved his
signature into the Hogwarts quidditch
pitch with 20 foot long letters created
a spell that shot a hologram of his own
face into the sky and even sent himself
800 Valentines and it was this
preoccupation with vanity that gradually
veered Lockhart away from hard work and
steered him in the direction of
insincere shortcuts in 1982 Lockhart
finally graduated from Hogwarts and it
was at this point in time they began to
travel all around the world this
coincided with him building prominence
as an author telling his readers Tales
of his heroism during his worldly
travels his complete collection of
published Works included break with a
Banshee getting with ghouls gilderoy
Lockhart's guide to household pests
holidays with hags marauding with
monsters 101 practical uses for Bertie
Bots every flavor beans travels with
trolls voyages with vampires wanderings
with werewolves years with the yeti who
am I and even an autobiography called
magical me where he highlights a life
dedicated to the eradication of the dark
Forces these books with the exception of
who am I were collectively written of
the Decades spanning 1982 to 1992
whenever he returned home to Britain
after traveling he would bring home with
him a fresh book documenting an
adventure that had purportedly occurred
during these travels these books were
not only self-promoting but also
contained numerous fabricated details
that were solely intended to Showcase
his ego and highlight his
accomplishments they were characterized
by gross exaggerations sensationalized
accounts and unfounded speculations that
lacked substance and when nothing more
than hot air and meaningless chatter but
still the public ate it up and Lockhart
began to gain considerable Fame within
the Wizarding World to them moves a dark
wizard catcher a dragon Tamer Patrol
conqueror if there was a dark and
Powerful presence in the world Lockhart
had vanquished it all by himself the
catch only he was there to witness it
Lockhart had really started to fill the
void for attention and validation that
he had felt since he was young and the
genuine praise for his accomplishments
came flooding in he received an order of
Merlin third class A Wizarding award
reserved for individuals who had
achieved great things for the Wizarding
World and was even invited to join the
ministry of Magic's dark force Defense
League in fact the praise for Lockhart
began to stack up so high that his old
professors at Hogwarts began to question
whether they had misjudged the confusing
young boy while he attended the school
with all of the success going to his
head Lockhart even tried out a career as
a posture creating a shampoo that
guaranteed lustrous locks of hair the
only issue was that the main ingredient
in the shampoo was too dangerous and
expensive to procure inevitably leading
to the shampoo's commercial failure
during the decade following Lockhart's
graduation from Hogwarts he would also
travel around the Wizarding World and
hold book signings by 1992 his Fame had
reached such a level that you couldn't
walk down the street without seeing his
face plastered along the insides of
sharp Windows however beneath all of the
charm and fame there was actually quite
a Sinister side to lock heart that
wasn't entirely addressed in the books
and films you see Lockhart was a memory
charm master and this was one of the
reasons that he'd been able to falsify
his existence so well Lockhart actually
wasn't a troll conqueror or Dragon Tamer
he was a phony and all he did when he
traveled around the world was to hear
the stories of genuinely accomplished
Wizards wiped their memories and then
claim the accomplishments as his own he
had developed a Sinister formula for
fame where he never had to face the
consequences that is until 1992 when he
accepted the post at Hogwarts as the new
defense against a dark arts Professor a
position that he was offered by
Dumbledore but why you may ask with
Lockhart whose Fame was growing
exponentially at this point take on a
position at Hogwarts well on
wizardingworld.com it's explained that
he was enticed by the opportunity to to
mingle with the famous boy who lived
hoping to have some of Harry's Fame rub
off on him and boost his own career even
further Lockhart might not have been
Keen to return to Hogwarts given how
well his career of stolen Glory was
progressing had dumbled or not dangled
the promise of Harry Potter over his
Fame hungry head by subtly suggesting
that teaching Harry Potter would set the
seal on Lockhart's Fame Dumbledore had
set a lure that Lockhart could not
resist the first time Lockhart and Harry
actually met each other was that
flourishing blots where Lockhart had
organized the book signing to announce
his employment it was also here that
Lockhart discussed several of his books
that had been assigned to his course for
that school year books which happen to
be particularly expensive during this
event Lockhart also attempted to
capitalize on Harry's Fame by taking as
many photos with him as possible
eventually going on to gift Harry a set
of his books the next time Harry and
Lockhart come face to face it's when
Harry shows up to his class in second
year it's here that he's met with
Lockhart exhausting but kind of
hilarious greeting me gilderoy Lockhart
order of Merlin third class honorary
member of the dark force Defense League
and five-time winner of which Weekly's
most charming smile award but I don't
talk about that I didn't get rid of the
band and Banshee by smiling at her first
order of business for Lockhart upon
arrival at Hogwarts was decorating his
classroom and personal office which he
adorned with self-portraits and signed
photographs his ego not stopping him
there he also made sure to fill the
office with copies of his Publications
in his very first lesson Lockhart showed
the class his true colors giving them a
quiz about his autobiography a strange
assignment for a defense against a dark
arts class only Hermione answered all 54
questions correctly and Lockhart awarded
Gryffindor 10 points he then released a
Cornish Pixies in the classroom causing
chaos failing to stop the Pixies himself
he asked Harry Ron and Hermione to clean
up the mess Lockhart's idea of class
homework included composing a poem of
one of his alleged achievements offering
a signed copy of his autobiography as a
reward to the best composer because of
Lockhart's incompetency I think it's
safe to say that his defense against a
dark arts class learned nothing that
year in this same year Lockhart got up
to all sorts of unusual Antics including
making a fool of himself at the first
dueling club meeting trying and failing
to mend Harry's broken bones and having
Harry help him sign his fan mail for
detention after Lockhart was hired many
of the staff were baffled with the
decision that Dumbledore had made many
of them taught Lockhart first hand and
knew of his ostentatious Tendencies
entirely unimpressed by The Chronicles
of heroism that he had since published
however it later revealed that
Dumbledore strategically hired Lockhart
to for a number of reasons you see
Dumbledore knew that Lockhart was a
fraud or at least suspected it and the
following excerpt from Pottermore
supports this Albus Dumbledore's plans
however ran deep he happened to have
known two of the Wizards for whose
life's work gilderoy Lockhart had taken
credit and was one of the only people in
the world who thought he knew what
Lockhart was up to
Dumbledore personally knew two people
that Lockhart had stolen potential Fame
and Valor from and so he must have known
that Lockhart's stories were falsified
because he knew the actual witches and
wizards that had accomplished these
Feats Dumbledore wanted to expose
Lockhart for what he had done but he
wanted it to come out naturally he
wanted to put Lockhart in a vulnerable
position so that he would effectively
expose himself we see talented wizard
though he was Lockhart had spent so many
years perfecting memory charms that his
ability in other aspects of magic was
very unimpressive Dumbledore was
convinced that Lockhart needed only to
be put back into an ordinary School
setting to be revealed as a charlatan
and a fraud Professor McGonagall who had
never liked Lockhart asked Dumbledore
what he thought students would learn
from such a vain Fame hungry man
Dumbledore replied that there is plenty
to be learned even from a bad teacher
what not to do how not to be but
Lockhart picked a particularly bad time
to return to Hogwarts but because you
see this was the year that the Chamber
of Secrets had been reopened it was a
tumultuous time at the school and
everyone was living in fear of Salazar
slytherin's basilisk however this
couldn't have been a better time to
expose him as whenever things got heated
Lockhart was quite obviously
uncomfortable and unsure of what to do
the other professors as well as some of
the students noticed this and he was
eventually told to go to the Chamber of
Secrets and deal with the monster
himself I think he was given this
Mission partly so that they could get
him out of the way in response to being
told to go into the chamber Lockhart
returned to his office in an attempt to
gather his things before fleeing the
school however it was here that he was
subsequently exposed as a fraud by Ron
and Harry the boys forced Lockhart to
come down into the chamber with them and
this is where things really went South
for him hoping to take control of the
situation Lockhart grabbed Ron's broken
wand and attempted to perform a memory
charm on them the adventure ends here
boys I shall take a a bit of this skin
back up to the school told them I was
too late to save the girl and that you
two tragically lost your mind at the
sight of her mangled body say goodbye to
your memories obliviate however given
that the wand was broken it backfired on
Lockhart instead the faulty one sent him
flying into a pile of rubble and
subsequently caused him to lose all of
his memories complete Amnesia he was no
longer the brave troll conqueror and
dragon tamer in fact he didn't know who
he was after Harry had taken care of
business in the chamber Lockhart was
saved by forks and brought to
mcgonagall's office it was here that it
became apparent to staff and students
alike that Lockhart had completely lost
his marbles and Dumbledore instructed
Ron to take him to the hospital Wing
after careful inspection it was decided
that Lockhart wouldn't be able to
operate in society in the state that he
was in he was subsequently sent to the
Janus that he woreed in Saint munger's
Hospital for Magical Melodies a ward
dedicated to those suffering from
permanent spell damage Lockhart remained
there for many years and he's briefly
mentioned again in the following passage
from the Order of the Phoenix but as he
stepped onto the landing he came to an
abrupt halt staring at the small window
set in the double doors that marked the
start of a corridor signposted spell
damage a man was peering out at the mall
with his nose pressed against the glass
he had wavy blonde hair bright blue eyes
and a broad vacant smile that revealed
dazzlingly white teeth it has been
expressed at Dumbledore never exposed
Lockhart for his crimes after being sent
to Saint mungo's and even though
Lockhart had stolen the glory of many
Dumbledore felt the Lockhart's fate was
already bad enough that there was no
reason to further step on an already
downtrodden Man by exposing him the only
result would be hate and contempt
towards a man that knew nothing of what
he had done Lockhart paid his dues by
losing his memory and his life because
Lockhart had never been exposed he was
allowed to write again and subsequently
continued his path as an author once he
had recovered somewhat writing the book
who am I with the help of the staff of
Saint mungo's during Christmas in 1995
Harry Ron Hermione Ginny saw Lockhart
and the Janus Vicki Ward and despite the
total loss of his memory he seemed just
as Lockhart as ever offering up
autographs and the like he had regained
just enough memory to remember writing
in cursive teach me did I taught you
everything you know I expect did I well
how about those autographs then shall we
say around doesn't you can give them to
all your little friends then and nobody
will be left out sadly Lockhart never
got many visitors but he's still got fan
mail from a wedge named Gladys gadjin
and developed a close relationship with
his carer Miriam Stroud though Lockhart
never made a full recovery he did sign
autographs for the rest of his days and
it has been expressed that he was
happier that way blissfully ignorant but
more than happy to reap the benefits of
his illustrious Fame to this day no one
knows if he ever properly left Saint
mongos and that's it for this video did
you guys ever wonder what happened to
Lockhart do you know about his early
life let me know in the comments section
below until next time remember there is
plenty to be learned even from a bad
teacher what not to do how not to be